hey folks here we are we might be drunk
we're back we're doing it we're uh we're
drinking we're drinking we got this is
is this our first International app
Daniel Sloss yeah it's uh am I popping
the like overseas Cherry yeah it might
be the hymen yeah I'm excited man I'm
excited we've been trying we tried to
get you last time early very early in
the we might be drunk days yeah yeah
well I think I would have been I was
that was about to be a lie so I'd say I
would have gotten more drunk then than
now because now I'm a dad but that's not
changed my drinking
like if anything when he wakes up in the
middle of the night you just have more
energy because you're like oh yeah [ __ ]
up I'm in the mood for crying this is
good yeah but hungover as hell but hung
over with a baby It's gotta be rough
yeah it does yeah yeah yeah if you don't
smoke weed oh hey more drugs yeah like
if you if you're willing to just sit
through a hangover and have a baby
during that time then yeah that could be
[ __ ] or you can just Coast out the other
end because you can be high with a baby
that's true you can't be high with a
toddler I don't think like once they
start recognizing the smell or you're
around other parents who know the smell
yeah that's what you've got to and like
nip it in the butt no pun intended
business
baby yeah yeah one for me one for the
baby one for me one for the baby
um but yeah man being high with a baby
is good because you you know I'll stay
at plants for 45 [ __ ] minutes if I'm
bakes as well we can just go in the
garden touch some [ __ ] flowers a
great day that's a fun day you can't
smoke I get so paranoid on weed I can't
do it I do I didn't realize until I was
in my thirties like now marijuana starts
giving me anxiety uh but when I was
younger because it was such a just a
cocky piece of [ __ ] who thought he was
God's gift to the world
like I think the paranoia did me a lot
of favors because like I would remember
being high my brain would be like you're
not as good as you think you are
everyone probably thinks you're a dick
and that was the first time those
thoughts had ever occurred to me yeah
and I was like oh my God maybe they do
and then I started being like do you
think I'm a dick and people were like
yeah definitely and I'm like oh this
isn't paranoia
this is just the truth yeah holy [ __ ] so
you stopped uh no no no I just smoked
more weight and reflected more on it and
then and then I now have an unhealthy
dose of anxiety which before I meet
people I'm like they are no they already
hate me yeah have you have the healthy
so uh dose of self-hatred it's not yeah
working yeah yeah didn't get that early
on just was straight into harmony
because I started on like a much smaller
scene than the New York scene right did
you guys start here I did yeah pretty
much yeah and like how how long was that
before you managed to like I mean is it
open mic nights like with Marcus and let
it open mind and uh but you know then
you find other ways to get on like that
we do the comic strip uh late night late
night there's there were clubs that
would put you on but you just get the
shitty spots you either while they're
getting the checks or yeah you're going
at the end of the night and that there's
it's funny you you get so mad about that
[ __ ] and I just wish I could have told
myself none of this is gonna matter yeah
you're mad cause some dude named angry
bob cut the line yeah that was his name
angry boss true and he was like I'm I'm
going on First and I was like there's no
justice in the world I'm like I did none
of this unfortunately your name's just
Sam
yeah obviously we're gonna put angry Bob
on first he's angry he flips the [ __ ]
out yeah that was his act what do we
what are we drinking here today we're
doing Bodega cat Rye Manhattans on the
Rocks thank you dear Jew it's a little
excited hey can we get can we get one
for Mike as well over here yeah Mike
wants one
all right absolutely who's my the agent
Pablo says publish uh well even worse
that is delightful that's very very nice
love a dark Sherry too so you guys don't
get that well I guess they're not any
[ __ ] weird uh like drinking
um what's what I'm looking for like
uh fears that you've got to do what did
you do what's this if you have to tap
the floor before you go on stage oh like
an OCD or Superstition Superstition is
what I'm looking for one in the UK is
you have to make eye contact well
cheering someone otherwise
you have sex for like seven years
I guess that's happening so I mean hey
hey we got a big yeah yeah there it is
yeah hey like I do I usually do the eye
contact when I choose just out of
respect well cheers apparently comes
from like the [ __ ] old days of like
if you were in a clan and the other
clans came to visit and you were hosting
them like you guys had to fill your
beers and your nails to the top and you
put all your drinks in the middle so
that your drink would slosh into theirs
and their drink would slosh into yours
just so nobody was poisoning anyone and
it was like if we all do this and we're
all drinking each other's drinks then
we're all cool one guy's still getting
poisoned way worse in the other people
it's like a teeny bit of poison oh yeah
everyone else is just getting like a
mild LSD hi yeah that's one of the like
choking holding his throat like Joffrey
you know like this gun can't handle his
ale it's unbelievable
so much of life back that was just
trying not to die yeah survival Mom
that's why handshakes where I was to
show your no arms that was hey here's my
short arm there he goes and there's
nothing in it and that's there that's
wild you're you're like a real Drinker
yeah yeah yeah have you been drinking
already uh not today uh not yet
um good job Mike I used to [ __ ] on
Americans so [ __ ] hard when it came
to drinking just because because we
sucked at it well that was certainly my
perception because you'd get Americans
being like you know because you guys
don't get to drink until 21. uh well
yeah yeah but like I remember being like
18 and coming over here and meeting 19
year olds would be like we're underage
drinking I'm like that's not 13 is
underage drinking yeah I come from yeah
like you do that too yeah yeah I I yeah
I guess it does I know it happens but it
feels just so much more [ __ ] you know
strict here and then it feels more punk
rock too or like I imagine imagine
drinking during prohibition here that
type of drinking must have been fun yeah
because you're breaking the rules you're
not supposed to be doing it like vodka
goes like down somebody's [ __ ] drain
in a [ __ ] ball because under seven
houses and pops up through a chimney in
the back and like the cops outside no
it's time for chimney vodka that would
have been that would have been the
[ __ ] base that's our next Blues
but that's where NASCAR came from was
Bootleggers trying to escape the cops
really that's the origin of NASCAR wow
give it a goog and they were only
escaping in one Circle yeah well that
was just never gonna end they didn't
know they were hammered but yeah they
would uh soup up their cars to escape
police
no that's Nascar May you [ __ ] go
just in case no one believed me
moonshine that fueled the growth of
stock car racing wow and Appalachia it
led to the rise of NASCAR interesting it
wasn't gasoline all right there you go
like the the big problem I
discovered with drinking over here in
this country is won the I never know
what to tip I remember the first time
coming oh yeah not understanding what
the Tipping culture was and I can't
remember which comic it was but they
gave me this advice and you can tell me
if this is bad but it seems to work for
me since which is whenever you get your
first drink
um I first of all didn't know there was
such thing as like drinking then a Chase
or whiskey like I'm from Scotland
Whiskey's the drink yeah and I don't
really drink beer because I think it
tastes like piss
um but I would go for like a cider and a
whiskey and I was like this is [ __ ]
great but UK measurements are 25 mils or
50 mils and you cannot give beyond that
because it's literally measured out
whereas here you guys are just like
how much how much is how much is too
much whiskey and you're like about seven
blinks of eye contact ago was when you
should have stopped you're curious in
the whole time cheers it's not breaking
that's the problem I couldn't look down
to check
um he goes just tap like five on the
first drink because then that bartender
will not leave you alone every time
you're up at the bar then beyond that
every drink you tip a dollar and then by
like the fourth and fifth drink they'll
just give you like a free drink BuyBacks
yeah yeah which again not a [ __ ]
thing so for my first time in New York
like did that and it all [ __ ] worked
I can drink five whiskeys in Scotland
and I mean not be fine but I know how
much I've had there whereas I'm three
whiskeys in America because I've tipped
this guy it's just up to the [ __ ] I'm
drinking it at the same [ __ ] rate if
it's a gin and tonic I'm like this
tastes different to the gin and tonics
back in the UK and that's because UK gin
and tonics are 25 gin 75 tonic as
opposed to if you've tipped a bartender
seven dollars hours it is Gen a bit of
vodka and then they basically just
whisper the word lemon on top but like
here you go
about that like you know where they
think they're hooking you up and the
drinks is horrible now oh brutally like
I got you and you're like that's I just
I would have just ordered a gin yes I
can't drink this it's poison but I can't
I can't not drink a drink same like I
gotta finish it even if it's like even
if it's a like a gin and tonic that I
know is going to be a problem for me
like it's my seventh one and I know this
is another four shots of Jen I'm like a
mature emotionally strong adult would be
able to self-reflect and go I don't need
that because it's already gonna be hard
getting home and I'm like but I remember
being 16 years old and asking people
outside of shops to buy me booze and
them not buying me booze and then like
having to go to that party sober and
being like I'm never gonna put booze
away again like if yes if it's ever in
front of me I owe it to 16 year old me
there's some sober kid in Africa
who needs me to drink this but I'm the
same way I mean remember we were younger
you know you go to bars and we couldn't
buy booze back then so you just I'll
just chug this lady's wine then I'll
drink this whiskey that's got a
cigarette butt in it but I'm putting it
down because just need to get a buzz
yeah yeah let that be a lesson if you
can buy kids alcohol do it do it yes
because otherwise they're still gonna
drink it right but they're gonna drink
stuff with cigarette butts in it
previously spiked drinks yeah you'd be
doing all these teenagers a favor if you
just bought them some Mike Hard Lemonade
you ever you ever get the bar there's
nothing they do here in the states is
they will you'll get them in hand
sometimes and you're like maybe it's
like 18 bucks there it's like damn
that's really expensive but they Pour It
Up to here so you're like that's a
[ __ ] that's three drinks yeah I know
you ever go on a date with a girl and
they're like okay and they don't drink
it you're like come on you're killing me
that was 19
I I was a bite when I was a single
single made me realize how much I don't
think I'm an alcoholic because it's not
like I need it to function I just love
it and when the opportunity arises
yeah but when I was on dates with girls
um and I was just by the way that did
not make you not sound like an alcoholic
I don't do in the mornings I don't do it
while I drive I'm like all right well
that still leaves the afternoon public
transit yeah yeah yeah oh man
they stopped public drinking on the
tubes in London and as the protest the
day before every single tube in London
was just people drinking on it getting
shit-faced handing out post to each
other because like we'll enjoy this
while we can hell yeah yeah and how else
are you supposed to get through public
transport oh my God if you're not sure
the problem is most people I know who I
drink with are good drinkers you get on
that train there's a lot of bad drinkers
yeah they don't know how to behave they
become they become the loud drunks
you're like these are the people that
should have quit yeah have you got any
friends that like you get to a point you
hang out with them couple times you're
like oh my God this is like being at
summer camp I've got new friends we hang
out oh my God we're texting a lot this
is where you hang out every time and it
gets better and better and you learn
more about each other and then there's
one time you hang out with them and and
it's either they drink too much or you
see the coke side of them oh yeah and
you just go oh now I've seen the demons
in the brain like you we left the top
off and I've seen the very dark side
yeah yeah that's how this podcast
started
well this podcast was originally called
one more drink right just based on the
fact that Mark and I used to hang out
like every night and drink and then at a
certain point you're on the road every
week and you don't see each other that
often so it goes down to like maybe one
or two nights you get to hang yeah so
it'd be me and Mark would be at the
Comedy Cellar and you guys we never see
each other one more drink
2 A.M one more yeah 4 a.m one more turns
into we're leaving at seven a.m and so
we're like it's that it's that Spirit of
like friendship where you're like oh we
we need that one more drink and that's
we didn't change it because there was
some podcasts with like five episodes
yeah we could have done one more if
they've only got five episodes they
cannot call themselves one more anything
they're quitters
that's true yeah we we'd had a lot of
long nights but the thing is you do have
that friend where you see the dark side
remember a friend he's like he'd be
really funny sober and then you get
drunk and you see him at the bar [ __ ]
face the bartender like sir get out of
here and he'd be like half awake like
get me a beer you [ __ ] and then he'd
fall over and I'd be like I think I
should get him out of here probably like
[ __ ] dead
but there's always the one who gets
coked up then you have the friend who's
a fistfight guy then you have the guy
who's grabby and uh then you got the
racist guy who you're like oh wow yeah
that came out the fist fight guy could
never fight either
yeah oh my God my fist fight guy we have
to like he's on a strict he's not
allowed to fight any one anymore just
because we I refer to women as scummy
Batman because you'll he'll never fight
someone who doesn't deserve to be fought
right it will always be he'll be sitting
in a McDonald's and then he'll see like
he phoned me once from Australia he's a
comedian his name is Kyle Humphries he
formed me in a strip from Australia and
he's like please answer the phone I
might be going to jail and I'm like
great here we go this is vintage guy
he was drunk uh a girl ain't got [ __ ]
faced and then about three in the
morning just had to go get like a
McDonald's and just [ __ ] middle of
Melbourne and there's a guy there with
his girlfriend they're having an
argument and like the kids behind them
make like a little joke of being like
keep it down or whatever and like the
adult guy loses his [ __ ] he's like and
you can't speak to me like that again
I'll put you through that [ __ ] window
and like she starts crying and while
she's crying he gets like the tray of
[ __ ] food and like throws it in her
face and it's like a [ __ ]
embarrassing me and goes back to yell at
the kids so Kai just like licks his
fingers
foreign
do you want me to knock him out like
through tears she just went yeah
he was like okay then he tapped the guy
in the shoulder the way he tells the
story is he's like he's left-handed so I
swung back put through the guy was like
six foot three goes through his [ __ ]
jaw and the guy like
turns around he's like and he's he could
be going down but he could be coming
back for the swing and he's way bigger
than me so I touch my shoelaces and I
swing from there and just knock his jaw
through the top of his [ __ ] mouth he
falls down to the [ __ ] ground and all
three kids just go run
and he [ __ ] runs out the McDonald's
he [ __ ] Sprints they spreads down to
the place where he's [ __ ] staying
that's what he's called me from and I'm
like what are you doing he's like I'm
gonna hide here for the rest of the
night this is like you know I've sobered
up now like that was like that's
dangerous he could have smacked his head
in the ground he could be like I'm
really worried like that second punch
was every
ounce of my [ __ ] being into him like
right like and he was not getting up she
was just over him and I was like well
Mike you have to find out whether this
guy is okay like you know that same
woman's like why did you do that yeah
well I love him
he goes back to McDonald's like 14 hours
later with a friend and he's like I'm
not gonna go in because everyone will
[ __ ] recognize me because I'm the
scumbag that knocked out the giant
he said it's his friend and then she
comes out and why'd he go back
he was so guilty that you know the guy
could have been smacked his head on the
ground dead or whatever like he was you
know after the he was in his head he was
like I was doing a nice thing yeah and I
was de-escalating the situation but
there's nothing yeah but there's nothing
more de-escalating than death
so like maybe I de-escalated it too much
sends the frame back into McDonald's and
she came back out and she'd been
speaking to all the McDonald's workers
and they were like yeah so like there
was this loud guy in a queue and some
kids behind him and then just this
random guy came out of nowhere and
punched him and the kids and he was like
no that's not he got consent
but like the [ __ ] Chinese Whispers
has happened in that 14 hours of just
gone from him being the absolute hero of
the story literally getting consent from
the partner do you mind if I knock your
husband out right yes please to I'm just
a random man that beats up men and
children a few weeks later like he rapes
babies
oh your heart is next
you know the sweet and sour rapist
but it's just like Batman he's
misunderstood you know everybody thinks
Batman's is devil evil guy but yeah
because he's scummy doesn't have any of
the cool gadgets it's just a regular
belt that doesn't fit
that's a badass way to say do you want
me to knock out your boyfriend that is
pretty bad chivalrous yeah there's
points when we put in like pubs together
or a situation I'm not a fighty person
I've never been a [ __ ] fight in my
life I've been uh Glasgow kissed once uh
that got headbutted oh yeah Glasgow kiss
it's called yeah Glasgow kisses ahead
but Glasgow smile is this is back from
like the Real Horror days of class going
like the [ __ ] 60s the same as Glasgow
smile was they would get two razor
blades and put the and face down on
either side of a credit card and that's
what they would use to cut your cheeks
because if you cut somebody with just a
regular razor blade you can just Stitch
that up and that'll heal fine but if you
leave the extra two millimeter thickness
there then those are scars for life and
that's what the oh yeah yeah real gnarly
[ __ ] thought out yeah yeah heroin in
Glasgow was a fun time for a lot of
people yeah
um the Glasgow case was me and my three
friends four friends including scammy
Kai were uh walking to a nightclub and
me and my three friends thought we were
shaggers and we we'd watched How I Met
Your Mother and we liked that show
because we were like 21 22 and we were
like we'll suit up because that's what
they do in the show and that's how those
guys get laid so it must work for us so
we're just three gawky [ __ ] early 20s
[ __ ] walking through Edinburgh City
Center with her suits on with Kai who's
in tracksuit bombs and a hoodie because
you can't buy a man of them right this
big Ginger guy sees me and my friends
basically I think that's one point
holding hands and he just yelled out
he's like you look like a bunch of
[ __ ] right and I'm drunk and I'm I'm a
young liberal and so I just start like
lecturing like something like even if I
am gay
even if I was gay I would rather spend
my entire night taking [ __ ] on my ass
and down my throat than spending an hour
looking like you you kidney bean looking
[ __ ] right and my friends
laughed and his friends laughed and he
went to say something else and I went no
no I won
like everyone laughed at my thing so I
won the exchange yeah and this little
thing is over and the next thing I know
I don't remember it but like I was sort
of falling back was my friend coming
he's stuck his [ __ ] he headbutted me
right up my [ __ ] nose my friend sort
of caught me and so I get back up to I
don't know give them another lecture
and Kai already has them on the ground
and it's just like that [ __ ] scene in
Sin City with a Yellow Bastard it's just
like punching his [ __ ] face into the
[ __ ] ground to the point where I have
to like pull him off of him and like his
friends come over and like what do we do
pull them off you're like and another
thing about gay yeah harmful well to be
fair the guy said we looked like a bunch
of [ __ ] I gave him a lecture on how I
wouldn't mind [ __ ] up my asses and then
my boyfriend jumped in
Spade I think he had a point not the way
he should have iterated it he should
have asked first
so I can [ __ ] [ __ ] up oh he's on a
strict [ __ ] band now from his wife
which is you've because we've seen we've
seen him not heaps of content and again
every single time always somebody that
started it or was bothering someone else
and it's always just been Kai finishing
it but man people knock their heads off
of carbs yeah like it's just one of
these times you're gonna do it and
somebody's gonna [ __ ] die and that'll
be the one cool story that we can't tell
and he's just going to be Nicholas Cage
and Connor yeah yeah like he was a bad
guy too but yeah oh yeah man if you if
you if next time Kai's in New York get
him onto this podcast get him drunk and
just get him to tell you every knockout
he's done in the wild because for some
of them are unfucking believable well
that's just confession there's gonna be
somebody listening wait a minute that
was me damn yeah we all have that friend
you kind of feel safe around him you can
say crazy [ __ ] because they're there for
years it made me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
because I mean I the reason I you know
the reason I'm doing it to fights is
because I can't [ __ ] win them the
reason I don't do MMA is because I know
if I were to learn how to choke someone
out I would be in jail within six months
because the second I know to do that I'm
gonna start applying my own Justice to
the world does anyone here think I'm a
[ __ ]
trying to use the skin I learned it's
like guns in this country I couldn't
live here because if I had access to
guns I would there's a hundred [ __ ]
percent at one point in my life I would
[ __ ] snap at minor Injustice I saw
whereas here I just I I get road rage in
the UK I shut my [ __ ] mouth in this
country yeah you could cut me off on the
[ __ ] highway maybe slam on the break
with my baby in the back and I'll be
like have a nice day you clearly having
a rough time there ma'am I uh I wish you
all the best hopefully you get to your
destination right on time no complaints
from old sloth balls that is our rep I
do think people from other countries are
like oh if you get heckled you can just
shoot the guy yeah you know on stage you
can't right
self-defense in Texas yeah no we I was
just in Louisville and uh and I'm doing
bits making fun of guns and out of the
gate they're like Boo and I'm like
perfect let's [ __ ] do this like
that's that's what I'm excited about
bits when they [ __ ] hate the setup
yes you know what I mean but yeah they
love guns there and most places in this
country oh I've had guys show me a gun I
was like what's this guy all about he's
like I was like carry on yeah just
joking Indianapolis and the guy in the
front row just showed me his gun damn
and that was uh and I don't think he was
threatening me I think it was like gun
banto but I come from a place where God
banter doesn't exist so I was just like
uh yeah yeah we actually have a term
called gun Play In America which is the
weirdest like uh euphemism gun play oh
it's I was in Indianapolis once and I'm
going back to the hotel everything's
boarded up like the you the the streets
shut down I asked the cop what the hell
happened here is it oh there was a
shooting right there it's shooting
around shooting around shooting around
that's basketball right that's not
murder exactly but that's how they
that's how casually I mean also the
amount of gun violence in Indiana is
insane oh really I think like per capita
is worse than Chicago I could be wrong
yeah but but to be fair there are more
people worth shifting there so yeah
I'm not saying they don't have it coming
I'm just saying right yeah damn I didn't
know that a lot of guns there how about
that well it's amazing actually more
people don't get shot in America we got
all this mental illness all this uh
opioid stuff and guns yeah we're doing
all right yeah
do you not think you have a lot of
shootings in this country oh I'm sure
there's one happening right now yeah
we'll hear about and that's probably one
in this building yeah
in New York City we have the amount of
that's how you know guns are the problem
when you're not mental health because of
the amount of crazy people in the city
true it's like you never on the subway
guys just come on screaming you're like
yeah I'm fine yeah yeah I'll do another
that's true we see dicks because they
have dicks yeah yeah they don't have
guns
who's the one Subway shooter but he
didn't even hit anybody he stunk he hit
like we don't have practice yeah that
was a stormtrooper oh no he's stuck he
was like an Indian in a John Wayne movie
he could hit [ __ ]
because well we only just introduced
them to guns there's no way yeah you
know he'll get there have you fired guns
oh yeah yeah shooting range is like a
Pastime here it's like you know fun I I
fired guns in when we went to Vegas it
was the first time I go into Vegas
is that you who did the shooting yeah
I couldn't believe how accurate was but
I tell you what I [ __ ] hate country
music
and I'll prove it anyway it's funny to
be singing about guns while getting shot
at by a guy with a gun would you reckon
anyone in that crowd was like I mean
this is ironic
I love my sick shooter
we went to just a gun range because I
was like when am I ever gonna get to
[ __ ] fight a gun in my life and they
gave us like a pistol and it was the
most terrifying thing because man I was
accurate immediately like it's just like
computer games like you aim at the thing
you should right you just go this this
movement should never be enough to take
somebody's life this is barely enough to
make someone come
like you can't you know just that
there's you know stabbings are brutal
but there's more like honesty and effort
involved it's intimate yeah they give us
shotguns prior to those those are
obviously accurate regardless I'd rather
be shot than stab the stabbing is like
it's repeated yeah it's more than it's
like the swordson used to have that big
remember that next one multiple times
true they do but but yeah maybe you're
right but stabbing there right on it's
almost like a hug it's like they're
[ __ ] you yeah and also it's a bit on
you like if you like if you got stabbed
you're like oh God somebody was within
five feet of me they go within my range
I was some you know I used to use my
black belt and carate whereas you can
just be shot from across the street and
you're like that's unfair that's true it
is unfair yeah it's my my biggest level
my biggest fear of unfair fairness
happening to me is I regularly gig in
Los Angeles and if I'm in that state
when uh the earthquake that they are 400
years overdue 4 takes place oh yeah I
just don't feel like it should be
allowed to happen while I'm there like
just like I would you know they'd so
overdue for this [ __ ] natural
disaster and I'm like I would just be
there trying to show the earthquake my
passport being like no I come from a
country that doesn't have this don't
come on like the one time you go visit
Yellowstone is the one time it goes off
and you're like well I know nobody else
is going to get these photos but I feel
like the one time I went to Wuhan
the one time I flew to in Malaysia
how did you make it back I don't know
the joke doesn't work
[ __ ] yeah oh we're doing was you switch
this to Scotch yeah we're doing
something a little closer at home for
the guests
16 as well that is that's good stuff
yeah really good year I assume you take
it neat right I absolutely take it I'm
not a [ __ ] Englishman
that is so good God damn that's one of
the best scotches yeah the smoke is
fantastic yeah the rocks are need as
well
four generations ago yeah when did you
guys become a country 1776 1776 how long
ago yeah
that was when our queen that just died
was just that she just got in there yeah
does that how do you feel about that
yeah okay you gonna make it yeah yeah I
mean The Hangover was fun
I'm from Scotland and I'm one of the
Scottish people that supports Scottish
independence so you know I I tried my
best to remember what Thumper said in
Bambi which is if you can't say
something nice don't say anything at all
I respect the fact that there are people
in the UK who are grieving the queen
because she was on their money and their
stamps and they liked that and they were
able to look past the fact that she
spent 12 million pounds of UK taxpayer
money in order to not have her son
extradited to out the whole Epstein
Island thing like you know if people can
look past that and grieve far fair
enough I'll not take away from that
me and the boys got drunk another party
I [ __ ] I hate the royal family I hate
the [ __ ] monarchy I think it's one of
the dumbest oldest is a crown is very
silly it's all funny I feel weird
wearing certain jackets right and you
think you're entitled to a crown yeah
yeah I just there's a level of
self-awareness I I also when Boris
Johnson said it was The Darkest Day in
the history of England I'm like settle
down yeah yeah no no what he means is
the darkest day of UK history that will
write about
like you've got to remember when Britain
discovered India right this was before
social media or like the news properly
existed so they just got to lie about
what they were doing there we were
trying to colonize the world and they
were like hey we found this big lovely
landmass it's hot there's heaps of food
there and we were like are there any
people and they were like huh
like were there any people on that
landmass and we got tea
yeah that's great can't wait to have the
team just out of curiosity were there
any people there when you were right we
we we taught them Cricket
we we only gave we only gave ignore the
massive totems of smoke coming from that
general area
like it's my problem with the monarchy
is especially oh she did so much she did
so much Britain is very like America in
the sense that
history is written by the winners yeah
so the stuff that the reason people
think they like the queen in the UK is
because they're taught about the queen
through the English education system
which was and one time she said hello to
a dog and there was another time she
kissed a leper on the head well it was
via FaceTime she did it on the screen
anything about Nazis in there yeah
what about the pedophile Sun the
pedophile Sun that we all know like he
was on television basically meant to be
appears to be a known pedo yeah I had to
get to live in a [ __ ] castle like the
amount of [ __ ] do you think you can
still get a massage
is it hard on a playground yeah that's
for sure what's the best of both worlds
it got to be a pedo and get away with it
yeah that's life in a [ __ ] Castle
but it doesn't I mean maybe I'm just
trash but look at that castle I'm like
it's so cavernous it's so like they got
AC in there
Central AC maybe in some rooms and the
internet connection
instant access to the dark web
is she buried yet by the way I mean they
really been putting that off
she gets buried on air Monday so it's
there's the whole thing oh wow ceremony
and things people in the UK like so
it's the exact same in this country
there's the left and right [ __ ]
device comedians sometimes fall far to
the left and far to the right and most
of the sorts fall in the middle and
we're like can we just [ __ ] please
because we're entertainers and it's our
job to unite that's the job is to
entertain and observe and just to make
jokes about anything nothing and
absolutely [ __ ] but when you go to
every part of the country you kind of
learn to connect to every part of the
country and your act does fall somewhere
in the middle yeah yeah I I and you can
work out like you've been like Okay so
this pro-abortion bit that I have in
this part of the country I don't need to
preface it with anything because I'm in
New York and I will just get a [ __ ]
Round of Applause I know that when I go
down farther south I'm not changing the
[ __ ] joke my material is my [ __ ]
material yeah but I will have to spend
maybe five or ten minutes beforehand
explaining more about Scotland what
about where I'm from what about how I
was brought up so that when that joke
comes in you know they still don't agree
with the sentiment of it and something
they completely disagree with but
there's enough jokes in there before
they're so funny be funny and at that
point it is just a hey this is a
disagreement of opinion and I'm not in
any position of power where I'm changing
anything no I'm just discussing [ __ ] and
occasionally making the [ __ ]
underhanded jokes that we all know
you're open with like look women are
objects we can all agree yeah but but
joke is coming yeah sorry man could you
please turn your objects to silence
seem to have taken umbrage with that
silence option on that oh wow the amount
of [ __ ] UK Comics there are now the
the the writer leaning ones that are on
Twitter being like you know this isn't
the time or place for jokes and you go
what on Twitter after one of the most
powerful women in the world died
I can't this is exactly if you want to
mourn [ __ ] do it in your house put
the [ __ ] news up but this idea that
you cannot punch up to a literal pedo
harboring monarchy and be like you know
yeah there were jokes about Kobe on
Twitter and Kobe's death is far more
tragic and Kobe was good at something
Kobe didn't make it to the Lakers
because his [ __ ] dad died he had
Talent right no disrespect to the queen
but uh fool fool full disrespect
and and every other app people that fell
off the pedo tree
[ __ ] no problem she was good with
corgis
yeah but no there were jokes about Kobe
and I [ __ ] personally loved Kobe I'm
a basketball fan yeah you know I had a
few but I mean somebody dies in the news
you're right about the news yeah that is
our Instinct with everything they go how
can I make this fun of course there's no
malice it's how can I make this funny
because that's that's our our job I do
think it's important you know in the
moments and tragedies afterwards I mean
Jason Nick said it best in the uh not
the thoughts and prayers thoughts and
prayers which is the the jokes on
Twitter aren't making fun of the people
affected by the tragedy it's making fun
of people who are online making the
tragedy about themselves that's good
those are the people that you know the
people are actually grieving the thing
are never online to witness the [ __ ]
jokes right you know we're just making
fun of everyone who's like and I'm also
sad today our job is to make jokes about
literally anything nothing is off
[ __ ] limits but I do believe that
there is a level of
responsibility occasionally to just you
know we don't get to choose how people
consume comedy or art you don't get to
choose how people interpret what you say
so I mean comedians like Jim Jefferies
who I think is [ __ ] amazing yeah I
imagine he might have a bit of a dislike
to some of his audience who don't see
the irony or sure only particularly like
the women are [ __ ] bits yeah yeah like
and I think some of his bits are like
some of the most thoughtful I mean the
gun bitterness
maybe the best bit of the last 25 years
it's every angle and then I think a gym
storytelling is you know the uh the
muscular dystrophy brothel bit is like
yeah
but there's but there's so much [ __ ]
empathy in that and that's what we want
it's not just like this let's get [ __ ]
it's not something like Teen comedy it's
like I'm seeing someone I grew up with
in you know abject misery yeah yes let's
make this funny and if you if you're
talking about taboo subjects which we
all have the right to do and they should
be [ __ ] joked about because the only
reason they aren't taboo is because
nobody else has the [ __ ] courage to
talk about them if you're talking about
those you do have a empathy has to be in
there and it just just so the audience
go to make sure that the laughs are
going in the right direction but I'm
going to make jokes about cancer not
about people that have cancer a lot of
people who have died of cancer but about
the Journey of cancer you go through
there I think there are some comedians
out there who are earlier on in their
career will watch people like Bill hex
Carlin Jeffrey's bar and they'll miss
the extra layers of understanding that
they'll just watch Jim Jefferies and
they'll be like oh rape is funny right
no that's you missed the three other
[ __ ] layers that made that cake
palatable exactly I hate when they go oh
so you think rape is funny it's like
well it I made it funny that's my job I
don't make it a joke I don't think rape
I think Jeffrey Dahmer isn't the same
thing yeah
I think it's funny he was a great comic
yeah well foreign
rape funny and like I don't find rape
funny but I can find you five rape jokes
I find to say the government's got some
really good rape jokes like people have
that I mean you said it perfectly do you
find this thing funny then why do you
find jokes about it funny and you go
because of the word Joe it's like the
main thing that made that difference
that that thing isn't funny because the
person the blessing of mainstream
success like you're talking about guys
that big like yeah you're gonna get fans
that are you know really understand what
you're doing you're gonna get fans that
don't know [ __ ] and latch onto the wrong
things it doesn't just have to be taboo
it goes the other way Jim Gaffigan bacon
is not inherently funny but you make it
funny yeah and now it's a big 12 minute
chunk oh man [ __ ] uh who's the uh his
name's I'm on the Moon Man on the Moon
Brian Regan Brian Reagan so brilliant I
I've stand up since I was like [ __ ]
five or six years old started on uh the
UK stuff just because my parents went to
comedy clubs before I was born so they
just watched it religiously so I ended
up watching all of their favorite
comedians and then I was about seven or
eight my dad introduced me to Bill Hicks
and I didn't get it but I I understood a
man swearing into a microphone and
finding that funny just being like you
can just say [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this is
amazing and then start getting more into
American stand up in my [ __ ] teens
and and still love who are you guys in
America uh
um uh back when he was alive Louis CK
R.I.P uh I liked I loved Bill Parr yeah
um I loved uh UK wise I was like Dylan
Moran Ed Barn love Dylan Moran
um I loved uh like stewardly I I think
surely is great but sometimes he gets
you know so far up his own ass yeah uh
but then in America when I started
getting into a bit more in fact when I
started performing over here I kept I'd
never seen him on stage I'd never heard
his specials people kept saying Brian
Reagan and I'm like who the [ __ ] is I'm
here on American podcast somebody who
the [ __ ] is Brian Reagan and the one
thing I keep hearing about him is he's
clean yeah he's clean he doesn't swear
he's not rude and I'm like there's no
way this guy's there's no way this guy's
good no let alone one of the best
there's no way this guy has [ __ ]
material that I couldn't [ __ ] write
myself if I gave myself two hours in a
[ __ ] office like because you clean
jokes about [ __ ] airports [ __ ] off
and people get I keep and then I hear
like Bill Barr talking about him and
like with genuine respect in his voice
I'm like there's no [ __ ] way this
clean [ __ ] can be [ __ ] good and then
I watched man on the moon and was just
like oh my [ __ ] god like and the
entire time I'm just watching it because
I'm like he's not sworn once none of it
and none of it's rude none of it's none
of it's like no victim except him no
yeah I I truly truly [ __ ]
mind-blowing okay I can't believe that
he makes little things funny he's got
this whole bit that bit is taped in a
comedy club it's just a set like an hour
set and he does uh he does a bit about
uh when you're a kid and you do like
ramps in the front yard and you know you
break your arm and you're like Mom Bobby
broke his arm and if you get peanut
butter get smooth
it's like it's something a kid would say
and he's so good how do you write that
we almost had him on here I will get him
but like it's not a situation to you or
I hit him up and I was like I see you're
in town he goes I'm leaving today and I
yeah but he said he'd do it and he
drinks and he drinks and one thing I've
learned about prime Reagan from I've
worked with people who have worked with
him apparently is sincerely one of the
nicest guys like it's just like the
sweetest like either a guy that opens
for me in Madison I was like and he just
took me on a night out because he found
out I was another comedian there you go
and that's you know whenever comedians
at that level still remember what it was
like to be a newer comic like that's I
knew that newer comic and that night
might have kept you going exactly 100
[ __ ] percent having that [ __ ] not
even supposed to be like to have that
[ __ ] story to be treated like a
[ __ ] peer by somebody who you think
is so far above you yeah can be fuel for
the next four [ __ ] years it's always
the funny ones who do that because all
the dicks are never funny the guy's like
hey don't talk to me you're not on my
level you're like well you suck anyway
and I'll pass you in five years but
Regan one time I was bombing in
Charlotte North Carolina at the comedy
zone this is 12 people in the crowd
bombing there's one cackle in the back
and I'm like well at least I'm killing
with that guy blah blah blah pouring
sweat I get off it's Regan right and I'm
like what we've never met we've never
hung out and he's like I was doing the
theater in town I was lonely you want to
get drunk we end up getting drunk for
seven hours and it was amazing and that
was it I met him in Jamestown New York
like Lucille Ball Comedy Fest they had
awful I pull up the the statue of
Lucille Ball oh I've been there it's the
worst looking thing no it's just why you
tell this can you remind me of who
Lucille Ball I know the name oh I Love
Lucy
classic Oh I thought you were [ __ ]
around first no no no no because that
show didn't I I and by the way I never
saw the show I Love Lucy I just knew
that right now Oh I thought that was
Rosa Parks [ __ ] pull up put a pull up
what she actually looks like she's a
beautiful woman hey that's a better
statue yeah also that's a little she was
a hot redhead in real life oh yeah oh I
mean the second one that you played that
was way more accurate than that first
year let me look at that that's a pin-up
right there did you ever see the uh the
god [ __ ] awful statue that somebody
did of Cristiano Ronaldo no and he's
like a hunk right yeah yeah yeah and
he's got an eight-pack he's like I'm
pretty sure he put a hit on the guy that
did this
looks like Sloth from Goonies
oh man the teeth are all jacked up holy
[ __ ] but the only difference is is that
statue is actually allowed in America
because it hasn't raped anyone
but it is in blackface but I met him at
the Lucille Ball Fest and he couldn't
have been uh cooler I mean Ronaldo no
no he's not alone in America it's like
he's just hung drank with us yeah this
guy and seen him a couple times since
and he is the nicest he's our scummy
Batman
I heard those booze here we need to
drink yeah he's a legend so he was one
of your guys and then I remember I
discovered you from your opponents at
your cones yes we're all Conan guys oh
yeah yeah well and and then let's let's
do what Colton never ever lets anyone do
on a show which is appreciate what he's
such someone for giving back to the
[ __ ] yes like truly understands what
it's like to be a younger newer comedian
and just I mean the support I would not
have my career in this country if it
wasn't for the fact that he took a
[ __ ] risk on half of me on the day
that he had me on because I still
couldn't [ __ ] believe it like going
up to the pain worn apart Warner
Brothers Park and I'm like this is gonna
get canceled last minute there's gonna
be something all good things are taken
away from me
get there Nelson Mandela dies
and I'm like
[ __ ] like this is [ __ ] it's
like obviously uh obviously I'm not
gonna be on the show because they got to
talk about [ __ ] mandelaide sure
enough according to like five minutes to
the top uh that's that's the epitome of
what a comedian is which is one of the
greatest man alive could die and you're
like but how does it affect my career
the other night I'm sure
this is worse than the apartheid
you think he was in prison
this green room's awfully isolated no uh
that so you but you went on that show
you went on I had a had a great one and
then like afterwards I think he tried to
like put me in for the next day and then
JP Bach was like just let him enjoy we
love you yeah
JP Buck is the [ __ ] money he gets it
he's the booker for Conan who basically
and the thing he's a producer he does a
ton of others yeah yeah but the thing is
particularly [ __ ] loved about JP
every year we go to the Edinburgh Fringe
Festival oh yeah just just to see what
the UK was doing he was like I'm gonna
find the best Comics here and I'm gonna
put them on TV in America because that's
my job was to find Talent from the world
and he would watch any [ __ ] I'd send him
to yeah like he'd come over take
recommendations for the [ __ ] weird
stuff for the great stuff for the
[ __ ] surreal
um and then yeah I mean and then ever
since then corner just came kept having
me Michael were talking about this
before we
don't exist in the generation of Comedy
where there is an overnight success
anymore sure like I mean if like
realistically
if I could take you back in time [ __ ]
30 years do you reckon Carson's calling
you over to the couch
I don't think I mean it's tough like I
mean there's that rare set it happens
maybe like if you keep I mean I do think
like
we all write a lot of jokes so I think
the hope is we get back on and
eventually make it up for the first time
my first Conan set wasn't great like I
stand by the jokes but the crowd just
gave me [ __ ] nothing and my second
one's my best TV set Bro like it's the
hardest I killed on TV ever it was like
I had a few drinks in me I was [ __ ]
but uh
yeah no that first one heard I was the
opposite first one I did great second
one I struggled
yeah I didn't like bomb but it just was
like every laugh was like yeah but dude
I'm trying to get [ __ ] that rolling
yeah you wanted to be magic
I mean it's as well as it can be set out
for comedy because they drew such an
intrinsic understanding of you know JP
unlike so many TV producers in the UK I
know for a fact that Kona producers
regularly attend comedy clubs and know
what it is but you're in a studio
there's lighting and also we're all
slightly darker than yes Conan and the
JP was [ __ ] crew JP let me do jokes
on that show yes
like there was a joke I used mass
shooting jokes on there I can't yes
I used to have a joke which was every
time I was doing British television
which was there's one joke that I knew
was it was just there so the sensors
felt like they'd done their job it was
an un televisable joke and you put it in
there and the sentences go through like
get rid of this one you're like Well
Done decades that's why I put it in
there so they ignore the rest of the
stuff because they felt like they did
very smart I sent that to entire State
through to JP and he was like great and
I was like what
can you tell us a joke yeah yeah very
easy joke uh my uh my mum's sister oh no
fire my mum said four kids so you can
tell she's stopped loving us over time
because she was blessed with me gifted
with my sister had my brother and then
she was diagnosed with the other one but
my mum's uh my mum's sister is uh
anti-abortion which is a cruel nickname
but she's had five
because it was on cable that helped a
little bit I remember the only note they
really said you can't the only thing we
ever said I can't do this joke I just
have a joke where I wish cancer on
someone it was just a part of the joke
and he goes you can't you can't wish
cancer on for Conan's National audience
you've not seen my last 15 birthdays
that's exactly what I did every single
time
this this is a year no
now word from our sponsor better help
you have to take care of your mind folks
we spend so much time taking care of our
skin our hair our teeth and so little
care of the most important body part the
brain how well you take care of your
brain affects how you experience life
investing time and energy and mental
health is crucial to being happy eating
right working out and getting plenty of
sleep are a good start but no
substitution for talk therapy better
help makes online therapy accessible
convenient and affordable we love
therapy it's good for you don't let
those bags pile up everybody's got [ __ ]
in their life everybody's got drama you
gotta make it work you got to be healthy
and that's how you do it is talking
about it that's how you get it out
better help is online there it offers
video phone and chat therapy sessions
you can choose to not see anyone on
camera and it's much more affordable
than in person you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours we might be
drunk listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com drunk that's
b-e-t t t e r h e l
p.com slash drunk get on it if you
haven't already it's smooth oh if you
haven't heard already it's smooth sex
summer the leading the leader in below
the belt grooming is making sure we all
have a ball this summer by giving your
pants
Partners everything they need to stay
fresh I love this thing you gotta love
the
manscape performance package 4.0 it's
got it all I use this thing on my sack I
go around the base of the shaft you just
want a little extra length and uh no
better equipment than these guys
manscape did it right they got a goddamn
headlight on the thing yeah and uh yeah
you can't Nick you can't cut I mean
there's a lot of veins down there and a
lot of uh precious material you don't
want to ruin I just use it man it's it's
I feel lighter it's great yeah it works
I had a [ __ ] fro covering my balls
yeah big fan our pubes look like our
hair so uh it's not that different and
you need a real I got sideburns too I
need a real mower down there the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and weed
whacker knows and ear hair trimmer
features proprietary Advanced Skin safe
technology to perfect protect your
delicate parts and holes both are
waterproof so you can shave in the
shower come on get it all out in one go
manscape even threw in two free gifts to
their perform orange pack is 4.0 the
manscape boxers and shed travel bag take
a look at the shears 2.0 a luxury nail
crewing git grooming kit I keep one of
my my bag all the time this kit includes
stainless steel nail cutters tweezers
and grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady in bed with those feet get 20
off and free shipping with the code
drunk at manscaped.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code drunk
at manscape.com it's smooth sex summer
boys get on board or get left behind
with your hairy ball bag hey folks we
might be drunk as brought to you by
raycon I've been listening to a lot of
Rodney Dangerfield lately and it's been
great whatever you listen to it'll sound
better with Ray con earbuds raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever they fit perfectly and
don't budge raycons offer three sound
profiles that let you listen to whatever
you want I love raycon I listen to it
when I run at the gym in an orgy when I
go to bed I like to pop one right in my
ear while uh while the lady's sleeping
next to me she snores like a angel
queefs and it keeps me up so I pop in a
raycon I I'm none the wiser I got an
audio book going maybe a little R Kelly
who knows get the same quality as any
other premium brand at half the price
with wireless charging ratecon gives you
eight hours of play time and a 32 hour
battery life 32. go to buy raycon.com
and use codes might be drunk 15. to get
15 off your raycon order that's code
might be drunk 15 one word at
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n.com to score 15 off by
Ray icon.com code might be drunk 15 and
get on it folks it was really
a pleasure working with JP a lot of
Bookers and it's not their fault you're
dealing with standards and practice on
these networks that are just like most
of these hosts are more concerned with
being liked than funny now yeah and
that's not what we're going for yeah you
know and that it will [ __ ] up a set yeah
of course but Kona was always so warm
like remember did he come in your green
room oh do the whole Spiel came in
beforehand also like one of my favorite
moments is my first code in sports is
Connor hadn't seen me before he just
trusts JP which again is another great
sign of a good boss who just goes
delegating full 100 trust the final 30
seconds of my clip-on code and you can
see Cody coming over to me and he's like
that's great and there's genuine shock
and surprise in his face that I was good
and it was like it's one of the clips
that I [ __ ] go back to and I'm like
oh man that like I in that moment I had
genuinely impressed one of the [ __ ]
greats the grades and you look up and
you go oh he's so big he's such a
[ __ ] tall man he also uh I mean he
was so generous and uh sincere I mean to
kill in front of Conan is the best and I
could tell when it wasn't my best every
once in a while you have one but yours I
watched all those late night sets at
that time yours all went viral yeah you
had Millions late night sets I mean they
were they were you watch a bunch and be
like [ __ ] this guy is is somebody this
guy's good yeah but you shared it with
me you're like this guy because we'd
always judge people and go this guy got
on because of this or he sucks then we
shared yours I was like this guy's a
comic whoa oh well I can't tell you how
much that [ __ ] means to me because I
don't know if it's the same for you guys
but the respect of your peers is worth a
Thousand Laughs from any audience member
oh huge like and also like for me I I
love
I never I never in my career thought I
would ever actually get to come over to
the states and perform like because
growing up being nine years old watching
[ __ ] you know Bell hexen prior and
knowing that this is where they come
from and how different British comedy is
and how different the [ __ ] scene is
and so few comics from the UK have ever
[ __ ] made it over here I mean I think
it's like [ __ ] Jimmy Carr Russell
Howard's kind of oh yeah yeah yeah uh
Billy Conley certainly made it into
movies
um Russell Brand but he's not a comic uh
um or up here
do you know him at all uh I know heaps
about him uh that are unrepeatable
what but not a not a good man wow great
chest hair great
and it's easier to come to terms with
because he was never ever ever good at
stand up at any point in his [ __ ]
career so it's you know I don't feel
like I'm bad-mouthing someday that went
through the trenches like we did he was
somebody that skipped a bunch of [ __ ]
levels became a [ __ ] TV presenter and
went I'll just be way he stole somebody
else's act in the UK ah you hate to hear
that yeah yeah I am
um well I got the [ __ ] Katy Perry yeah
yeah is it worth it
and then and then dumped her like really
like 20 minutes before she went on stage
like there's a Katy Perry documentary I
haven't watched it but like the advert
for it is like apparently like literally
20 minutes before she goes up he her
husband like if there's officially too
many documentaries yeah
Katy Perry documentary that's crazy
she's like still young yeah I know wait
till they're like 70 or something you
know yeah but what if she dies before
then and you know we can't we will never
get a good Winehouse documentary because
she had too much fun too young what
happened to her
what so yeah so she dumped her right
before she went on oh like like it I
again not was the the advert for the
documentary is like her getting a text
backstage and then like 20 minutes late
horror and chairs being like pushed up
like
first of all
I have in my younger years dumped
someone by text now as an adult I'm like
it's a it's impersonal it's you
shouldn't dump people by text there are
some times when it's fine like if it's a
crazy person and you're getting out that
relationship and you're like I've taken
the stuff the house is yours goodbye
yeah you can break up with someone who
takes that yeah you can
divorce someone via text like that shot
you can't just be like you gotta just
screenshot like take a picture of the
divorce papers right and then just via
WhatsApp send that through and then
you're like just reply with a tech the
lawyer says that counts
can we not discuss this no sir no no
can't do baby I'm I'm playing London
wow you get the papers they're still
buffering she's got to sing Teenage
Dream yeah after hearing that [ __ ] damn
damn all right I had no idea about the
the Russ yeah no he's not hey I mean
I'll tell you most off off camera I
can't wait patreon
so you came over here Conan was awesome
new anyone any like were you doing weird
uh American markets when you came on
over here I was so my big thing when I
first came over was just to I didn't
want to [ __ ] skip
I want to cheat but I also didn't want
to be sent like to be sent back a couple
levels like so when I started in
Scotland I worked my way up to become
like doing 20 minutes there and then
when I after two years I started going
down to England and they were like and
now you're doing fives and tens and I'm
like
okay I get it I understand it's a bigger
[ __ ] Market I've come from you've
Scotland six million people overall and
the population of London the capital
city of England is eight million right
fine this is a different thing and this
is the main comedy scene what I am and I
go down there and I restart it again and
I worked my way up through the fives and
tens and eventually we can you know
[ __ ] headliner at places like that
and then when I went to Australia and
they were like great so we'll have you
in pretend and I was like no but in
actually I had to do it again I had to
do the tens and 15s and then I'd done
like
I think uh oh No in fact my first gig in
America I hadn't even done corner I
think I just done setlist oh yeah I
remember yeah and it was talking about
sure man it was so fun and again I loved
the fact that they filmed it so for
people listening setlist is basically
you just get you just get a word right
yeah well like my set list for tonight
would be like uh dead old lady
like a kitty airplane but whatever and
these are just the notes that we have
that let us know what the next two
minute three minute five minute whatever
that is whereas what setlist is is
[ __ ] Troy would just come up with
random scummy Batman on the screen you
gotta go with it I'm gonna make it funny
and you have to protect not only do you
have to make it funny you the people
that sucked at setlist were the people
that went oh this is a weird one the
whole point was yeah you gotta own it
you had to Pretend This is the set that
you do regularly this is your normal set
and every comedian this is a weird one
this is a great response this is a weird
word like you're a comedian yeah look at
it get it [ __ ] going yeah
um so I mean there's so many great
comedians on it because EV I mean I I
would be on with comedians have been
going for 25 years and they it was the
first gig they'd ever been nervous at
right for so long because you know
you're going in front of an audience
that you know is hot you've seen
everyone else have a decent enough
[ __ ] gig but you do not know what
you're going to say and you don't have
any of our jokes to fall back on like
we've all got bits when we're like if
something's going badly there's one joke
I'll do and if that joke goes badly it's
just in my head I'm mentally shut off
right just like I'm like if they didn't
like this there's nothing I'll get
through it I'll professional here are
the words here's the performance whereas
you don't even have that in a set list
you have your weapons if you're on stage
or like this doesn't work I'll save it
but yeah in that in that environment you
got to save it if you can't even go to
[ __ ] audience stuff because like the
audience won't respect you from going
away from the thing and then where you
guys from
a part of this I saw Kyle Kinane do it
in Melbourne and it was amazing he is so
good off the cuff yeah he's great
um so I did so I done the sellers TV
show which I don't think I [ __ ]
accounted for anything but it was still
in the Middle Ages of this sort of
Internet so enough Americans had watched
like British TV shows on YouTube and
stuff so today and for Comedy Works is
the first ever comedy club in America
spoiled oh Beyond one of the best like
truly one of the [ __ ] best magical
ever oh and the stack for the memories
that tells album was wrong I had no idea
good day to cross the river that's
that's important there some of the best
comedy albums ever I got in there on
like uh I got in there on a Wednesday or
Tuesday and then the shafasia was on the
Wednesday and then I do the show and it
was everyone was so nice uh like
obviously some [ __ ] teething problems
with like references that don't [ __ ]
make sense sure and then I say to the
staff afterwards and they were like it
was great uh and they're like and I was
like I'll see you tomorrow they're like
it's Thanksgiving tomorrow I'm like okay
I'll see you in Thanksgiving and they're
like no it's it's Thanksgiving nothing's
open right like like did nobody tell you
this and I'm like yeah British don't
really celebrate it's kind of [ __ ] up
to bring you in on that yeah yeah well
but but when I get the hotel paid for
and everything so but I didn't realize
and they're like are you not doing
anything for Thanksgiving I'm like I'm
I'm Scottish I'm not doing anything for
Thanksgiving the staff from [ __ ] uh
Comedy Works took me to their staff
thanks Kevin my first ever Thanksgiving
was them cooking stuff I'd never seen
[ __ ] yams with [ __ ] marshmallows
my favorite
man the Judgment that came out of my
mouth and that went into the oven and
I'm like you know what some stereotypes
are true yeah
that is a [ __ ] Abomination we never
should have let you become your own
country this is disgusting and then and
then three hours later after like
fireballs going around and I've smoked
unlimited spliffs I'm like this is a
gift from God
and we sat in the table and I remember
like because it was I mean Colorado I
think it was like two months before
they'd legalized marijuana no because we
went to a guy's house and his entire
bottom floor was just him growing weeds
and he's like if the police don't arrest
me in the next two months
Denver and we got so [ __ ] high and
they made us you know they were like
everyone shared what they were thankful
for and it was really [ __ ] nice so no
like I'd been [ __ ] on Thanksgiving
in America you're so [ __ ] long and
then to actually be at the moment I'm
like oh this is actually really nice I
can't remember ending the next day like
they made me because like weed over here
is a different [ __ ] concoction it's
wild you know to get the to get weed in
Scotland you have to get in the back of
a teenager's car where his child is
strapped into a seat
and you're like and he's like what are
you after and you're like wait and and
he's like okay here you go and you're
like what type of weed is this and he's
like wait get out of the car I'm like
that's whereas when I was in [ __ ]
Denver for the first time Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory yeah a man you know
some of them have like cheese and
crackers out you're like
it's like a maitre d they're like this
is the Glasgow smile
it's way better than the Glasgow
headbutt yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but Matt like they were like [ __ ]
scientists in there I remember oh yeah
the guy who went to me because he could
just hear my [ __ ] accent he's like
well you're not from here and I'm like
just give me some weight and he's like
buddy you can't you can't walk into a
chocolate store and ask for some
chocolate like what what type of high
are you after and I'm like
I just get like shitty Scottish weed
like I just want to get high he's like
all right what's your plans for tomorrow
oh well you know I'm I'm waking up I'm
gonna go for breakfast and then I've
I've got show in the evening so I don't
want to be too fat for that so you can
go on stage high yeah really I can't I
can't do that really no we're not weed
guys anyway we can maybe oh well if
you're not Stoners then fair enough but
like like I'm well there's a question
for you are you yourself on stage are
you 100 yeah I think so yeah a little
more elevated a little more energy yeah
it's it's a heightened yeah yeah yeah
they're jokes I believe in they're jokes
that you can stand behind but yeah I'm a
[ __ ] Stoner in real life so there was
times when I would be on stage doing
jokes that I'd written high and I'm like
well this isn't genuine right right to
be I didn't I I never used to I would
always drink on stage not heaps but like
when I was first starting out I remember
I remember exactly it was my 14th gig
and I was in a place called Dundee in
Scotland and they were going to say
about 30 people in this audience and up
until this point just being a comedian I
was just yeah I mean I put you you're
just doing impressions about the
comedians there's no you in it you're
just doing what comedians do I didn't
have the ability to take a drink during
my set like that was such a I'm like to
take away your weapon right like you're
on stage you're talking to everyone and
nobody's heckling but like if you do
this it's silent and you feel it yeah
it's like holstering a [ __ ] gun while
everyone else is aiming at each other
yeah couldn't do it
and finally got to the stage where it
wasn't even alcoholic drink but it was
water and I remember coming off stage
with my dad who was still driving me to
gigs at this point I was like did you
drank water on stage
what a dad yeah it is a power move to
take a sip on stage you saw such a
problem well the biggest thing I learned
from early on in comedy which was I
would always run to the mic get out the
stand and start talking while it was in
and it was Frankie Boyle who said to me
he was like Mark your territory like
Market go up take the mic acknowledge
the audience don't acknowledge them
don't be rude we don't have to talk to
them take the mic out the stand put the
stand wherever the [ __ ] you want look
look at the stage work out how much
you've got to work with and all that is
is just going I am 100 [ __ ]
comfortable up here wow this is mine
that's yours and uh because it says
you're in good hands too yeah yeah
because I I always say the audience are
the smartest and dumbest people at the
same time they're Schrodinger's audience
if you are nervous if you're genuinely
[ __ ] nervous and scared they will
sniff that out from the street outside
and they'll not come in they'll be able
to see it so easily but if you can fake
confidence which is surprisingly easily
Too Fake once you learn how to [ __ ]
do it they can't tell the [ __ ]
difference that's true like if you're on
stage and you're eating [ __ ] [ __ ]
because they don't know you're eating
[ __ ] because they don't have
10 000 reference points
we have a cake and we're like this is
about you know in the bottom 20 of my
gigs they don't know the average
audience member sees every once in a
while I'll tell them yeah yeah so you
guys know it's a pretty bad gig for me
that's true you guys suck
well but that was the biggest thing I
learned from doing the Edward finches
everyone was like you cannot ever blame
the audience so yeah it's like well that
makes sense yeah and then just still do
it occasionally during the French you're
doing the same show the same show at the
exact same time every single [ __ ]
night with the same [ __ ] Cadence and
you go oh no this is you this works this
is absolutely [ __ ] you that's the
most frustrating thing about comedy you
shoot a point in basketball it goes in
the basket it counts but our joke that
works they don't laugh you're like whoa
whoa I've done this joke 900 times this
is on you yeah come on there is I I
fully changed my stance if it's never
the audience at all I think comedians
have the skill to make any room [ __ ]
playable and if you're in a position
where you have to make that room
playable and you can but also you get to
a certain point in your career where if
you're successful enough you look at a
room full of people that hate you and
you're like I don't want to win you over
because I don't want any I don't want
any of you can't connect your wife my
brother I don't have that yet
well no I look at them and I'm kind of
like I think they also value
self-awareness so sometimes I'm like if
it's going badly I'm like I'll tell them
like I know this isn't going well yeah I
don't want you to think that this is a
[ __ ] win for me and that helps
sometimes it helps but then also as
you're saying like if it's going badly I
mean I'm doing new [ __ ] like and I know
there's a way I could win them sometimes
I'm not done doing that new [ __ ] I'm
here to work too I'm here to build an
act so I can adapt at some point
sometimes I'll even tell them I'll get
you but I'm doing these [ __ ] jokes
yeah I'm here to work yeah yeah you know
and also there is there is sometimes
just our audience where you go
I'll [ __ ] get you and it's not in a
way I could ever repeat like
if I've recorded this show none of the
material I'm about to use can never be
used again yeah Daddy specifically
calling you are you old Specky [ __ ] and
you you miserable [ __ ] breasts and
like turning the you know I think I I
always admire comedians that are you
know when I say the [ __ ] back of the
room and I go
I'm just worried about how my material
is going to go down and I know I'm not
really going to stray from my material I
might I'll change the performance
obviously I'll
catering that way but the jokes but
comedians that just go on and be like
you know what [ __ ] it play the room
you're given and I'm just gonna you know
be be weird and be wonderful and [ __ ]
get them back on site because then you
get to follow them with normal stand up
and you're like right now that you all
remembered how to laugh did we all have
a slight refresh
my [ __ ] mother-in-law let me tell you
I hate that though I had a set last
night where I had to do eight minutes
and then they're like all right we trust
you and then I did another seven and
you're like what I'm the same guy but
that's the brakes too long yeah they
don't know you and there is a humility I
think the way we all approach stand up
where if you try to turn over material a
lot you're gonna bomb a lot you have to
and you're just not going to get a big
head you can't get a big head if you're
writing a bunch of new jokes because
you're gonna fail too much yeah true
true I mean Louis CK we say like he
would go to New York and rip yeah dog he
would bomb for three months in in New
York and you're like this this is the
guy what the hell happened what's going
on and then three months in one day and
you're like that was brilliant I don't
have that kind of I really no you're
cushion it but he was doing an hour I
wouldn't cushion it but I certainly like
so the way the way I've done this show
that I'm doing now is uh my son was born
in February and this tour finished in
like Gloucester finish in like June
but they were spread enough that I was
kind of writing jokes in between so I'm
at most eight or ten spots over the
course of six months wow the comedy
clubs in Edinburgh just trying like the
new thoughts that I had out and then
just went to the French and the show was
a work and progress show and it was
pitched as a work in progress I didn't
give them any [ __ ] artwork to use it
was like the lowest price available like
people need to know that they're coming
to see me just go through yes [ __ ]
notes Here uh and for the uh Vegas man I
don't get nervous much before I go on
stage even with [ __ ] new stuff this
job is to if you truly love this job and
I I think it's silly to get nervous
beforehand unless it's a particularly
big gig I trust myself I trust my work
and I why would I let the greatest thing
that I get to do be dampened by some
[ __ ] stupid little illogical [ __ ]
fear I've always been able to very
healthy yeah I've been able to nap
what if you do badly and the department
remains like well statistically we're
good
like I got the same memories you do
buddy I know anxiety is powerful but
here's cold hard [ __ ] logic we'll be
fine mentality what's like what you said
about Carson how like that overnight
success no longer really exists so
neither does that overnight failure
really oh that's good I mean to some
degree with the people on the in the
woke you know well yeah mentality and
[ __ ] on social media in both sides
obviously not just awoke but uh but it
is harder to get ruined overnight I
think yeah yeah well well I also man
cancel culture and comedy
yeah we're all doing all right I don't
worry about it I don't worry about the
jokes did you get canceled or did you
get a bunch of free publicity that you
could before like
the people people that were never going
to see you are still never going to come
and see you and now a bunch of people
know you say controversial [ __ ] and
that's who you want in your audience
like kids and now we get rewarded for
saying crazy [ __ ] when we said crazy
[ __ ] before I'm still the same guy any
any anytime any of my friends have been
[ __ ] canceled I've just been like
first of all you're just being yelled at
online which took him wrong is an
unpleasant experience it's very
unpleasant they're hugely unpleasant and
also people take it too far there's dark
thing there's fear it's like it's like
if you die it's that is insane so I'm
not I'm not saying that aspect of cancer
colleges doesn't because of course it
does that's [ __ ] horrific but if
we're talking about
perspective if you have a joke that goes
out there and it's a joke that you're
proud of that you'll [ __ ] stand by
regardless and a bunch of people hate it
good those are people that were never
going to come visit those aren't your
audience members
yeah I'm like okay yeah when they write
like uh you just lost the fan like you
weren't a fan yeah if that's if that's
all it took I had to I I have I had a
fringe where one year basically I'd gone
from being like sort of cheeky chappy
young teenage comedian like oh aren't
mum's weird and you know uh underage
drinking blah blah blah and then I did a
show which was basically God's not real
drugs or class and [ __ ] everyone that's
not me yeah and every day during that
[ __ ] Fringe I would watch minimum and
whatever the ticket sales to prove it
minimum 15 people a day walking out of
that show because they'd all seen me do
TV in the UK but it was all
pre-warershed TV so it was all very
clean no swearing and nowhere near to
the degree that Brian Reagan does any of
it ER and every day I watched 15 people
leaving and there was that constant
Temptation in my head of the community
to be like going I could win them back I
could win those people over yes I could
do jokes that got them to come back in
the room but I'm not going to because
the people that are staying like I've
you've got our art art isn't for
everyone and that's the fun of it okay
which is is this art do you think 100 I
think so really absolutely absolutely no
no I I don't think it's you know if we
take art as a spectrum and I know how
the right hate spectrums but you know if
you know if autism is a spectrum and
success I suspect and all this stuff
on the spectrum of our I don't think
we're necessarily up there with the
musicians and actors despite the fact
that some of the best actors in the
world happen to be comedians by the you
know Robin Williams was particularly
[ __ ] good Bob bars becoming a
surprising because I can't do what we do
they [ __ ] cannot and musicians cannot
do what we do because Madonna bombed at
[ __ ] Jimmy [ __ ] Fallon yeah I
opened for her I think what we do is
yeah well I'll Defenders I think it's
absolutely a [ __ ] art I don't but
it's not it's not a high-end art it's
very low end yeah yeah yeah but that's
what's great about it yeah the low end
is good but that's why I find it so so
funny because occasionally you do get
comedy snobs and you're like man you've
got to answer all of this all of this
entire sense of humor comes from Lower
Class A human itself comes from people
at the bottom trying to make anything
good out of that situation and sometimes
the only thing you can make out that
bottom situation is laughter people at
the top living in [ __ ] castles don't
need to make each other laugh I heard
that Cassandra was funny
but no you're right look I mean all the
minorities the oppression they're all
the funniest some of the greatest jokes
in the [ __ ] world must have been told
in Auschwitz oh my God they must some of
the will never do those are pretty cool
now some of the [ __ ] greatest
comedians in the world came from that
[ __ ] time
yeah like comedy comes from the bottom
laughing up but that's where it comes
and just laughing from bad stuff and I
and I moved my stuff up to you when
you're down yes but we talk about people
getting mad and I do think if comedy is
a low end art then if it is people
getting mad is a good thing because
where do people get mad at they get mad
at [ __ ] Tarantino they get mad at
Spike Lee they get mad at like these
filmmakers who are considered artists so
if people get mad at comedy I think it
legitimizes it as that type of low end
art right a comedy's not low endar it's
just not high-end art we have the the
reason that we hate saying that it's an
art form is because whenever we think of
art we think of [ __ ] museums we think
of yeah we we're going to do this big
weird [ __ ] sculpture that costs 20
million to make and it doesn't mean
anything and it's made of spoons and
that means and it's about the artist's
relationship it with his mother and
you're like we spent 20 [ __ ] million
that's that's upper class [ __ ] art
but yeah if we when you look at lower
class R which is jazz
which is can be done by [ __ ] anyone
in well I mean not anyone obviously
you've got to have access to musical
instruments but original Jazz didn't
come from that comedy is lower class art
which is making its way up to the
[ __ ] middle classes and I don't think
the upper classes will ever truly get it
but that's fine they keep imposing or
opera on people [ __ ] orchestras
that's all their [ __ ] all these 25
million pound patents is all them being
like this is RR and you all have to
Value it whereas I think comedy is art
from the bomb and it's much harder to
get it to that middle section because
they don't care about what we do but we
care about what they do that's
interesting that's well said yeah
sometimes you see what those Christie's
auctions go for a piece of art and
you're like are you out of your [ __ ]
money you could take any [ __ ] bit of
art from the center of [ __ ] New York
and take it to some of the poorest
people in America and I guarantee you 99
of them wouldn't [ __ ] appreciate it
you can take a [ __ ] comedian from New
York and put them in any part of America
and I guarantee you they'll get more
depreciation from that yes with
comedians I think are
uh unwilling to call this an art form
because of the negative stipulations
that come from because it's an attention
yes pretentious and comedy is
unpretentious it has to be it has to be
well you've not seen my confidence
how long are you at the Soho theater for
I'm there to uh uh Sunday uh but I mean
this is just first of all I just want to
be on the show
thank you you're ever you're ever in New
York you're gonna come back come back
you're such a great guest
um
I'm coming I'm touring America with this
Air Show eventually I've got three
specials coming out later this year just
my wife three three yeah yeah so I add
uh when Netflix gave me the dark and
jigsaw specials I already had like I um
the way the UK comedy scene works is you
write a new hour every year because
that's how the Fringe the fringes every
August so you write show for August you
tour it until December you've been that
show and then you spent January to July
writing a new one to then take to the
fridge again and that's the class that's
the how high school works in the UK
um so I mean now I don't do it in that
way but if you feel like that's too
quickly ever oh at the start yes if you
ask anyone about my first second or
third friend show uh they were probably
early [ __ ] diabolical and [ __ ] and
was way too long for a comedian of my
experience to be on stage doing what was
let's be honest 30 minutes material
stretched out to 60 minutes with other
stories that didn't [ __ ] make sense
but it did absolutely give me the work
ethic of turnip [ __ ] over every year
now I'm not doing it every year now now
I'll do a new show every two years but I
would not be able to do it had it not
been from you know the first 10 years of
my career was 10 brand new shows every
single year wow all do you ever feel
like at that nine month ten month Mark
you're like I gotta really pull some
[ __ ] together here yeah yeah I might not
be dead honest about all my work there's
some shows I think fall well short of
other ones uh but also natural yeah but
I've also learned again because this is
an art form
um we do not get to choose how audiences
consume our art and how they take it so
the shows that I've done that I hate
that are the most popular ones amongst
my fans isn't that interesting yeah and
it's really interesting like I'll come
off stage and be like I [ __ ] hate
that and there'll be people saying I'm
trying really hard now to basically not
ever let my audience know how I feel
about any show because my perception of
it is so far removed from what there's
yeah why do you think that why do you
think there's that discrepancy why do
you think because I it's it's still a
imposter syndrome on my part like you
know to you know I love the fact that I
get to Gig and American I love the fact
that I'm you know I'm fighting on [ __ ]
with you guys uh to do shows like this
and you know the comedy seller are
always so nice to me whenever I go down
there have I never seen you there they
oh because like man I don't I don't jump
up
oh really no no because for me and this
this is all me issues it's not anywhere
anyway anyone at the sellers ever made
me feel I can't like the staff have
taken me on [ __ ] nights out there
like there was a party that they maybe
come to get [ __ ] on I love the sale I
love every part of it every time I've
played those rooms it's been you know
again you can't understand the Scottish
comedian who grew up as a teenager
watching people play clubs like that
okay that's [ __ ] but it's still it's
just when I I feel like a foreign
[ __ ] exchange student of course who's
just put into this [ __ ] school and
it's a new pecking order like you know
in the UK I'm not really on the scene
anymore because I just I just tour and
then I come to the states and I didn't I
didn't have to start again here thanks
to Conan's stuff I was able to sort of
get in with the clubs here but then
getting straight into the [ __ ] clubs
here
I
absolutely felt like oh [ __ ] I've I've
skipped the queue and people have been
like who's the [ __ ] Scottish [ __ ]
right yeah this is international yeah
weird because you know in the UK you're
probably moving tickets and and here was
it weird to be like Oh I'm not selling
as many tickets it was it was that a
weird transition so because now you are
obviously yeah well no no there's well I
mean the first when I was student
America for the [ __ ] first time man I
couldn't the good thing was at
especially Comedy Works in Denver they
were all sold out because the Comedy
Works is such a good reputation that
people will just come down to see what's
ever on there so there was a bit where
it wasn't shifting tickets at a certain
places but I never I never perceived it
that way I always took it as man I'm in
America and 30 people in Indianapolis
have turned up to see me live like
that's a [ __ ] achievement you know
that's not it's not how I want to play
the room but I can punish the 30 people
in the room who made the [ __ ] time to
come out there but you know the New York
scene to me is the most respected and
therefore the most [ __ ] intimidating
one and I remember you know the first
time I was invited to [ __ ] sit down
at the comics table at the cellar which
you know growing up listening to
podcasts and watching [ __ ] Louis was
like this is unbelievable I can't
believe I'm part of that you know to go
away for a year and then do the rest of
the world where my career is going and
then come back and say that table with a
different group of people who've got no
idea whose [ __ ] Scottish Macaulay
Culkin is right right back up and again
nobody else has made me [ __ ] feel
this way I've never felt [ __ ]
unwelcome I've never felt ostracized
this was like what do you want to say 10
years ago that I was texting you about
Daniel yeah it's like like we thought
you were funny for so long so it's it's
funny like you know you do have that
feeling like oh New York but you know
you're you're killing it man yeah you're
doing great
the Soho Playhouse is one of my [ __ ]
favorite venues because they were the
first one to put me on when I came over
to here like and they um like day one
day one I played to nine people it was a
six day one day one I played the nine
people uh day two I played to 13 Day
three I think I played to about 4A and
then on day five it's like a 180 serial
room and you can see both of them and
I'm on stage and there's about 50 people
in the audience and it's New York and
I'm like everyone's in New York you know
it's this everyone tells all these
stories
and I look in the crowd and I'm like oh
my God
that's that's cow pain oh wow
and also the guy that wrote All of
Obama's speeches you know was part of
that oh I didn't even know that oh yeah
Manny's part of a band was campaign and
I see him I'm like there's no no I'm
doing this tiny little [ __ ] New York
Rod there's no way it's him and I do the
rest of the show and I don't mention
that I go through and then after that
I'm like I'm almost certain that was cow
pain and I go downstairs and I get into
the bar of the Soho Room uh so I saw her
Playhouse and there is just an Indian
man there and I'm like oh I'm a racist I
was just like an Indian guy in the room
and if he does look a bit like in my
case but maybe this stage lighting makes
me less racist and I I say hi to him and
I take a photo with him even though he
doesn't want one but because I have all
this like white guilt of like Oh I
thought you were just another famous Pro
man but and then and then I go outside
and I check my Twitter and Carl pebb was
like hey man I came to the show I'm
around the corner if you want to drink
yeah yeah when I turned up the first
thing I said was like buddy you'll be
pleased to know I'm not a racist I
recognized you from one other Indian guy
showed the other night and I was like I
think Martin Luther King is in the crowd
tonight
it must have been a dream
well he's kelp in he should be thankful
for crickets yeah
um so I mean so whenever I come over
here I tend to do the playhouse because
I also
man I do 75 minutes and that's like and
and because uh uh I'm fortunate enough
to be at a position where you know when
I'm turning the world to you know I'm
I'm doing 75 minutes going back to 10
and 15 and 20 is fun and challenging and
sometimes I [ __ ] love it but uh I
mean they've asked me to be on this
seller a bunch of times here which was
my [ __ ] dream when I was you know
even in my 20s for the Sailor to be like
please drop in would make 25 year old me
rock hard yeah but then I'm just like my
show finishes at half nine and my son's
in bed okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah that makes sense
yeah uh well I gotta I got a show there
at 10 30 if you want to pop in tonight
yeah I'm just throwing it out there but
I know you're you don't want to be a bad
father
no but if but excuse Mark over your son
yeah right and I could because you being
there would get me over my [ __ ] even
though all the staff left me in a
consistently welcoming you need a bridge
I just yeah I just I'll be there too
well yeah I just need a playmate I just
needs like a little [ __ ] you got both
of us
I'll be there yeah yeah all right I mean
I'll have to I mean I'll when I say run
it past the fiance
yeah I'm running some new stuff oh yeah
me too I got some horrific new me too it
stinks oh great then I'll absolutely
come there
those long sets are the best where you
just are like oh I gotta like really
like why would you want to do 20 minutes
when you could do 75 that's why people
make fun of me for doing the road I'm
like that's why I do the road I get
material out of me that's where you work
out but you both did the I mean and and
you saw the I don't know if you know
this but yeah the example that's used in
the UK when it comes to how there was
this period of time in comedy that
[ __ ] existed where Netflix was
suddenly that that was and and as
someone that had two Netflix specials I
can tell you the experience of that
almost Carson level of overnight [ __ ]
success where things [ __ ] changed but
there was this huge gap in between
between like everyone went specials on
Netflix Amazon Prime were offering them
and we were all like yeah yeah I can
wait I'd rather work in one of your
warehouses than give you an hour of my
[ __ ] material yeah but because
because people browse Netflix nobody
browses Amazon I do sometimes but not
for comedy yeah but it's on Amazon and
chill
I know
and then there was just this huge
[ __ ] Gap and then you guys finally
[ __ ] I mean you know you released them
on [ __ ] YouTube and for so long that
was such a I think it was seen as almost
uh Counter Culture
yes it was a failure I put it on [ __ ]
YouTube and then you proved there wasn't
because I'd said for years to my [ __ ]
agent I'm like because I'd seen when Bob
barnham remember Bob barnham released
war on YouTube before I bought it like
it got a hundred million views on
YouTube before Netflix we're like oh
[ __ ] we need to take this wow I knew
from that [ __ ] moment I'm like it's
if you can find you know how to spot
Talent
100 million views
comedy should be a meritocracy and
sometimes it is there are certain stages
in this job that it is you know if
you're on the open mic scene it's a
meritocracy because the best comment
will eventually arise on top of that and
then you'll start getting on other
places but then there's this new layer
which is kind of meritocracy which is
you're the best but there's also agents
involved in producers and TV and there's
all these other things that are coming
in that are [ __ ] up the audiences
not their enjoyment of it but how it's
being translated into work thereafter
they're like okay you obviously were
brilliant but we've got two of you so we
actually want this person who did much
worse but that's a different market
right and and this would start happening
and don't be wrong I still think because
of this job because of the nature with
the audience there is the chance of
meritocracy of people getting to the job
and that's why I think the internet now
in in the past two years has become
actually such a powerful tool for Comics
because the comedians that were and I
I'll hold my hand up was one of the
communities being like I'm not doing
Tech talk I'm not doing Instagram reels
I'm not doing these [ __ ] little I'm not
going to write my subtitles on [ __ ]
15 minutes 15 seconds stand-up clip and
burn that material there was this real
snowberry from Comics like [ __ ] three
years ago being like well no we're not
doing that and then certain people
[ __ ] did and it [ __ ] blew up
because of course you were giving your
material in the best possible format
just out there to the world and you know
what let's say at best 50 didn't [ __ ]
like it but the 50 of the Dead came in
and went we want more because that is
how capitalism you gotta stop playing to
the back of the snobby room comics and
start playing to the people that are
buying tickets to see you we just want
to sell tickets yeah yeah and also
they're jokes it's not how many people
some of those Comics who are snobs who
were [ __ ] on us or posting pictures
of sunsets uh I'm posting my [ __ ] act
yeah yeah I'm a comic oh but well
because you two were more I would say
it's basically from the perspective in
the UK you you took the jump into that
well before most of our Comics because
now we've reached critical mass so many
people are now doing I'm even [ __ ]
tweeting and [ __ ] this graphic
stand-up stuff because I'm like oh this
works this is what we now agree this is
a system that works yes when you guys
were
starting it was there any of that like
of course yeah I can't show respected
[ __ ] on me for it and it didn't feel and
now that I could tell like I should have
done but I can't you know he turned a
YouTube special into a Netflix special
that's right you're the first person to
do it from the opposite [ __ ]
Direction you know I don't know if I'm
the first there's other people but like
you know I I want a weird route where I
did two Comedy Central specials then
YouTube yeah then another YouTube and
then uh and now Netflix so it's weird to
go starting with the industry love but
it's Comedy Central so it doesn't do
[ __ ] for you because no one [ __ ]
watches TV at 11 p.m on Friday yeah so I
have to build a special come on and then
YouTube so then back to like the
industry and Industry side that actually
helps with Netflix you know yeah yeah
you got to make it yourself it's weird
to go to go like like that kind of you
know but right uh but whatever works you
want in the end YouTube is now becoming
oversaturated because so many Comics are
doing it like I swear to God we get hit
up every week but from a comic like I've
got a special coming out and we're like
yeah there's a special every [ __ ]
week more than every week because
there's more than 50 Comics oh yeah but
the market has to be is you put your
stuff out on whatever the sources are
whether it's [ __ ] Twitter Tech talk
and Instagram and you
pardon me you put out your content
whether that's a 15 second clip of stand
up or if you can get two minutes so what
you're doing is you're just sewing seats
you're going here's what I do and
obviously you get some people like we
hate that we don't want that [ __ ] you're
like all right well [ __ ] off but people
who like it will then come in and I
think that's what TV ignored for so very
much is the fact that if people really
like something if they really find
something that resonates with their
[ __ ] heart they will go out of their
way to [ __ ] consume it like I had one
of my Netflix practices for whatever
[ __ ] reason I'd never expected this
went cult like it's the a show that
broke people up right I remember that
yeah it was never the intention it was
just a show about toxic relationships
and about me getting out of this
relationship and it was sort of like a
real rally against people in fake
relationships man one of the 13 shows
I've done in my career for whatever
[ __ ] reason this hair part of how
many couples did you break up at the
moment well I can't even couples were at
500 000 and divorces I'm at
550. I'm still mad at you
you're right you never know like Bill
Burr said he walked off stage after that
uh Philly rant and he was like well Goes
My Career I just [ __ ] my career up and
then look at that it's one of the most
badass moments just because like it was
insane that bill even had to deal with
that but the fact that he just didn't
banjo like he's just yeah I mean the
most quotable [ __ ] bet and I've done
it when bombing just to make the
comedians of the room at the back of the
room laugh as you just go seven minutes
like if your gigs ever going back like
four more minutes
he just keeps going he goes hockey terms
I mean yeah bill just I mean that was
like the moment I was like I already
thought he was a great comic I was
already a big fan but uh yeah the fact
that he just didn't bend oh man that was
when I watched uh level of stand-up that
I was like all right I'm never gonna
reach that I'll never have the courage
and I'll never have the the brazenness
yeah and also because he was able to do
it because I think you because he did
have such a love of Philly itself right
I with that audience you know he was
able to just you know they just booed
you for no reason they were and yeah I
mean they booed damarera off stage Dom
is a [ __ ] amazing comic great comic
Dom's been an amazing comic for almost
40 years yeah that's why he was Bill was
pissed he was like you're gonna Boo this
guy [ __ ] you
damn off stage Dom's are one of my
favorite bits you ever heard his bit
where he when Comics will go true story
he goes who cares say something funny
like anyone's getting like anyone's
after a show it's like man that Dumber
or a stunt but boy did he have integrity
that's a great Dumber Arabic great joke
he's great yeah but you never know I did
a million of these late nights nothing
they don't sell tickets you know but
then I did a Morning Show with some lady
and I was drunk or hungover and that
that popped from those shows sell
tickets clips from the show I'm not
saying they were look professional they
look yeah yeah of course look as we said
there's no more Carson no it's the
internet but but I think when there was
no more cars and we comedians sort of
trusted it to be left up to Hollywood or
in the UK the [ __ ] BBC to make these
careers and there's just been this time
when we just sort of trusted Executives
and producers to pick us out of the tree
and decide yeah we want to go whereas
what we're realizing now and and look I
could be wrong in the same way that when
the internet came out people were like
and now the internet's here will all
become more intelligent and somehow
friendly we all became Dumber so this
might be me saying one of those things
preamp but I believe now that because of
the way social media is working and
comedian's abilities to put the material
out there regularly into a wider
audience I do believe we're going to see
a slow death of Television because
you're going to have comedians that can
just thanks to their social media tour
because people will eventually find them
because there's this algorithm that
another company created that certain
people will be watching certain bits of
material and then they'll be introduced
to your stuff or my stuff or your stuff
and then they'll and then they're
suddenly in our algorithm and they watch
our stuff and without watching
television and without ever going to see
stand-up comedy live they're now
introduced to us as a person and they'll
buy tickets to a show and people that
work in television will go
oh wait hold on you're selling Out 3 000
seats every day yet you don't have a
television on the BBC and you're like
yeah this is because you don't know
what's going on yeah they're almost
middlemen
they've always been [ __ ] middlemen
but they had power before yeah they had
middlemen before because there was no
wonder this because they were the they
chose what audiences saw and that right
has now been taken away but it used to
be people that worked in television yeah
they chose what was entertainment and
now thanks to the internet nobody gets
to choose what entertainment is anymore
people get to choose what they're
entertained by and thanks to this
algorithm that was created for the
opposite [ __ ] reasons people you know
Finding artists that they've never seen
before and can now it's the more I mean
this is why patreon's so successful now
because this is the first time in the
history of entertainment that there's
ever been such a direct [ __ ]
relationship between artists and fan
yeah and it's not for other people you
don't have to soften your material for
other people you know you don't need to
weaken what you're doing to appeal to
the [ __ ] masses you can offer them
the opposite of that which is what the
audience want which is more you
I like you right I think you're great
whatever this is I [ __ ] subscribe and
it takes a while to become used to that
like I I still blows my mind than I have
fans but when you realize you're
Advanced man they love you it's like you
know you just have to look in the same
way that you look at musicians I love
this and I'll listen to everything they
produce there are people that feel that
way about comedy they're people that
people that way about paper mache yeah
sure welcome to the [ __ ] weirdness of
the world yeah I mean furries no no no
they do all have to be killed
on air every furry like I'm not here to
[ __ ] King Shame but if you're a furry
die die die
there is something about you know these
these Gatekeepers I get emails from my
agents now they're like this company
wants a general meeting and I'm like I'm
good yeah what a great feeling oh uh uh
this company they produce penis Island
can you meet with them on Zoom for 60
minutes
be all right I'm uh you know I'm gonna
go to the [ __ ] coffee shop audition
for that penis Island
uh no addition for the island
they wanted me to be the penis yeah
Epstein's Island sorry
yeah yeah it's true but that's Freedom
that's nice that's the nice thing about
having fans yeah you know you got your
own people you got your own Army and
then eventually they'll they want you
yeah they want your people and that's
when it's just easier that's when you
just make the show you want without
concessions
that's why I don't do any circuits as
much but I'd [ __ ] love to you know
spend two weeks here doing all the
[ __ ] clubs every night but in 100
honesty it's
laziness I I have my audience yeah he
don't justify my laziness
I need to punish myself mentally and
I'll not have you ruin that
um but no even before my family were
over whenever I was in New York I would
be invited down to The Cellar but I'd be
doing shows here and be like no I'll not
do it and I should because I love I love
going down there but I'm at a stage now
in my career what I'm so [ __ ]
fortunate the fact that you know
whenever I go I'll find my audience and
that is
whether they know it or not that is the
comedian Street which is you know we
don't we don't want to appeal to the
[ __ ] masses unless you want to be you
know the worst of comedians sure you
know I I don't know who the worst
comedian is publicly seen as in the
America but in the UK it's Peter K
nobody messages of the show it's
absolutely Peter okay
I know who that is
you never will because these are a fat
Manchester comedian who just did
Nostalgia uh on State and look Alan
Sultan because I think he's personally
[ __ ] is a comedian
can't sells out Arenas he's one of the
most quote comedians in the UK his work
ethic is secondhand can't take money in
that good [ __ ] joke right here really
good with audiences
okay oh because there's enough stories
about Peter K off the circuit where you
know what is his stage Persona is
different to his actual real life
Persona and also it's straight down the
middle comedy and not with this skill
and humor that Brian Reagan does it
don't compare just because he's clean
doesn't mean he's Brian Reagan he
doesn't have the talent that Brian
Reagan I don't even know he was I wasn't
compared oh yeah and if you were to
watch you wouldn't understand it because
it's very specifically British it's
Nostalgia about British Union oh yeah
and man again again you know him at all
uh I know of him through people that
have worked from him which is why I have
my perception of him as a human being
and that is an awful one
um but I love the [ __ ] shots fired
who's gonna touch me at this point on
after you
oh there was a joke I could have done
there but it would have been cut
oh really oh boy all right there's no
more cutting in the city now that dear
Evan Hansen's closing so so I gotta
you're you're we we stay around America
we do Canada we meet England you know
maybe Ireland what's a crazy country or
city that loves comedy that we don't
know about like out there overseas I
don't know if you did that intentionally
but you genuinely listened to every
other country apart from Scotland there
oh yeah well I put that all in there you
gotta I gotta go there do I have to go
to Scotland yeah once it was yeah yeah
you should you should go to The Fringe
but not to an hour there okay because
the hour We're especially with your you
would do a good I want I think you'd do
an exceptional but I think you would not
enjoy it because it wouldn't be like
doing an hour at a comedy club like when
you go to Edinburgh uh it's the largest
Arts Festival in the world you have to
understand that there's only two things
globally that sell more tickets than
they had in with fringe and that is the
Olympics in the World Cup
wow wow the third is the French it
doubles the population of the city there
are 2 000 shows on a day 500 of which of
Comedy uh the drinking laws change it's
the city I live there the rest of the
year on the the city [ __ ] changes
yeah
um the mistake that a lot of American
comedians make when they come over is
they're expecting it to be like a comedy
club Vibe which if you do the stand or
you do monkey power The Comedy Club to
look at that but you're doing an hour
there's nobody on before you there's
nobody on after you it's just EU and
that's a difficult transition that being
said
I've seen plenty of American communities
smash over there because you don't fall
into what the Brits do over there
you don't create a narrative you don't
really care about your dead dad you
don't have a musical number at the
[ __ ] end you just do a solid [ __ ]
hour 50 minutes of [ __ ] material and
don't get me wrong first week is
difficult because audience is coming in
and working at what they like but then
Word of Mouth helps and then by the rest
of it you're having a great show because
I mean [ __ ] uh Britannic uh American
uh sketch Jewel came over and I only saw
them on the final day and they were one
of the best things ever yeah why do I
know them do we see them in Ireland Mark
I think one of them is the brother of
Robert Michael Henny oh okay okay yeah
yeah I I think it's absolutely worth you
doing the French but the way you should
do the friends you just come over and do
three nights there because what the
french does and the mistake people make
with the fringes you have to go back to
The Fringe every year because you have
you are building your audience every
year you go on stage you play at 70
people
seventy percent of that like next day
next year you move up to a hundred
you get sixty percent [ __ ] turn rate
but word of mouth has helped to take out
there then next year you move up then
the next year you move up then next you
move up
Australian comedians are famous for it
they'll come over have three great
fringes in a row and then not come for a
year and then they'll come back and
they'll be like where's my audience gone
but like they thought you died right
like this is the French if you want to
become a [ __ ] French comedian and
successfully keep French you have to do
it every five every year every year but
you can you can come in and drop it but
Barnum is coming in and uh well to be
fair to ball Bo did a two full fringes
uh and then came back and dropped in uh
Bill Burris dropped in to do three days
at The Fringe uh
um this year I his name escaped people
come in and just [ __ ] drop and yeah
because it's a Sean Patton who's done
the film as well yeah yeah one of the
most underrated comics in our country
and he's got a new special on YouTube
yeah and was underappreciated in
Edinburgh for about two weeks until
they've had to the audience found him
and then he started [ __ ] smashing it
because that's the way the process works
unfortunately to be fair he's
underappreciated here too so that's just
his thing we love him it's because he's
so aggressive
but yeah three days all right that's the
move because a month is such a
commitment no no I would no no come over
for come over for two weeks and do three
man experience the festival you you
whatever I tell you about it doesn't
matter you have to experience it for you
to because you'll you'll experience a
different Festival to me yeah you'll
find different places that are actually
really good to play you've got to
understand this City opens up rooms that
are closed for the rest of the year to
become venues so you go into this all
old [ __ ] room where there's water
dripping off walls and 50 people are sat
in there and you're like what is this
for the rest of the year and they're
like nothing this is where people used
to be tortured like we just felt like
they people have performed in
cult closets to three people the there's
tops of buses like it's wow you just
don't I wherever I sell you and whatever
I tell you about it will be a lie
because your experience of The Fringe
will be different yeah but that doesn't
make your experience with The Fringe in
your life you have to go over and I 10
days is the best because 10 days is the
ultimate holiday anyway right two weeks
is too long one week is too short if you
were to go for 10 days and you were to
put on two shows at a good venue which
you could put you in with
and the other eight days you decide what
spots you want to do because there's a
thousand spots a night uh you could do
late in live you can do [ __ ] spank
you can do monkey bar you can do any of
the [ __ ] weird [ __ ] that's going on
there's other weird comedy shows where I
did one this year where the comedian was
there were two actors on stage and your
job as comedian was to just direct them
doing Macbeth hmm no car no no standard
comedy just for an hour two people do
Macbeth and randomly you just as the
Director with a microphone chipping with
how you think they should be doing with
Beth and that's the show that's fun well
it was the funniest thing I enjoyed it
so much at the time in my life there was
such funny comedic actors uh
you know
you could go to The Fringe a thousand
times and never experience it in the
[ __ ] same way there you go you just
gotta that's a good sales pitch yeah
maybe we'll go the same year I would
love to go all right maybe we'll do it I
hear it I'll set you up with maybe we'll
do it live up with see the shows we
never do it now we're talking do they
drink out there
let's do it all right I've always been
intrigued but I keep turning it down for
more money don't no no no come on do not
do the full run and do not buy into any
winter if you want to if you want to
[ __ ] take the risk it can work out
for you and I would
recommend it if you can do the full run
I think there's so much learning in it
and I think it's such an important bit
of [ __ ] learning uh that if you want
that you'll benefit from it hugely if
that's what you want then definitely do
it but
before that I would recommend you just
go over to the Friendship because
there's there is nothing like it so you
cannot make any rational decision on how
you want to do it before going there and
being like oh [ __ ] this literally
doesn't happen anywhere else in the
world right to I hear you all right it
sounds I mean Michelle wolf had a great
time Ari loves it Patton loves it
um canane oh Harry gave us horrific
mushrooms one year on the left on the
second last day of The Fringe I met one
of the artist bars and he was like a fan
gave me these I took 120 minutes ago and
it's great and I was like I don't like
mushrooms he's like I do and I'm telling
you as a friend this one's safe and I
took it and then like 40 minutes later
he came up to me he's like I made a huge
mistake
hi this is [ __ ] by the way the number
one guy who tries to get me to shroom
yeah he's sorry he's like we got a
shroom
terrible [ __ ] endorsement all right
yeah yeah
and because of that I say [ __ ] the Jews
I think I'm Gonna Get Us flagged on
YouTube
I made a killer episode and they're like
we're pulling this it's not called
YouTube what plug some gigs Dan oh yeah
uh just man uh before you buy tickets to
come see me live go on Netflix watch my
huge uh Netflix questions YouTube
specials Jesus watch dark and Jake saw
uh I will also be releasing three
specials on my website uh before the end
of the year uh so wow yeah but they're
from previous shows that weren't picked
up by other places but we filmed them
anyway to a professional level
and they're good if I if you enjoy
enjoyed dark and jigsaw they're better
than those ones because they make it
they came after those ones yeah there
you go that's the way to do it highest
endorsement great comic so yeah
uh yeah and plug some gigs too uh oh
would you want me to pluck the [ __ ]
Dublin Newcastle Vilnius all these great
places.com I I do Europe heavily I do
Lithuania whoa uh Estonia uh Belgium
Germany France Italy all the ones go and
my I I yeah I do everywhere
I'll tell you I've done Europe a good
bit and I ate my ass in Belgium have you
ever been there yeah yeah yeah they can
take a while yeah yeah oh man did I die
in Belgium everything else was great
that Antwerp was weird was that with
Bert yeah
you've been there oh we you went without
Christchurch yeah well that explains why
it's weird yeah like Belgium wasn't
ready for Burke Christ
Scotland was amazing yeah we're watching
Scotland we did Glasgow some uh
some kind of warehousey looking place oh
the garage
yeah yeah the Cottages it was one
[ __ ] classical history man yeah great
time I got a Lexington Kentucky I don't
know did we do Phoenix ready Lexington
uh New Brunswick OKC Springfield
Missouri Fort Wayne Indiana Happy
Thanksgiving to me uh Kansas City
Missouri Tacoma Spokane more shit's
coming big tour announcement coming soon
uh and watch my Netflix special same
time